welcome to the last development kit
sneak peek come on this is cool so hi
I'm Timothy Jordan I'll be your
developer advocate for the next I don't
know forever you can reach me online at
google.com slash plus Timothy Jordan
because the conversation doesn't need to
end here
also check out developers.google.com
slash glass slash community you can find
links to our Stack Overflow tag our
issue tracker and we can continue
hanging out even when we're not in a
room because the internet is really that
cool we've got a lot to talk about today
I'm just a handful of things that we
need to do up on the board here we're
going to talk about the glass platform
and talk about the components the
building blocks of glassware we're gonna
spend a little bit of time asking the
question what is the GDK but it's not
that existential it's very clear and
straightforward and then we're gonna
look at some development paradigms or
patterns for glass so it sound like fun
alright so let's jump into it first off
I wanted to say note about glass and
glass is this really cool thing as we
all know in this room that gives us
access to the technology that we love
without getting in the way and that's
very cool but what's even cooler is that
it's a way to build services for users
that they can use in a natural and
everyday way in their lives and we knew
this was awesome when we started
building the hardware and software at
Google we knew it was going to be even
cooler when you built the things that we
knew you were gonna build on this
platform but even more exciting is the
stuff that we couldn't even have
imagined that you've started to build
and you're yet to build now that you
have access the GDK that really reaches
these users in their everyday lives in a
way you could never do before glass was
available and that's the glass platform
you've been building on it using the
Google mirror API which is a restful
web-based API and those services that
you've built
there's only a handful of them that are
available online and even though it's
early days 83% of glass users have at
least one of those third party glass
services involved and installed which is
a huge number for just a handful that
are available to them now again the
mirror API is what you built these on
and it's a cloud-based API that allows
you to insert timeline cards respond to
user notifications and do sharing from
glass you can do a lot with the mirror
API but you've been asking for more and
we knew we needed to give you more and
that's why we built the GDK and we
talked about this at Google i/o this
last Google i/o and we've been building
it since and we're going to tell you all
the details about it today there are
three major things here that you can do
on glass now that you couldn't do before
the first one is offline you can now
build code that runs on glass so the
user can use it whether or not they're
connected to the Internet and you can
also get real-time immediate user
response all right so this is a
glassware that's installed on glass and
the user can interact with and there
doesn't need to do a round-trip to your
service in the cloud to be able to
respond to a user request and then
finally deeper access to hardware such
as the accelerometer and the GPS now
these three things are cool trust me
they're very cool we're gonna get into
detail about how these are implemented
at the GDK but before we get there I
want to show you so we do a demo right
away okay so this is word lens on glass
and I don't know if you've had this
happen to you but I've had it quite a
few times where I'm in a foreign country
and there's a sign like this and it's
like that guy looks like he's having so
much fun I want to do that but maybe I
should read the sign first you think and
so typically what I'll do is I'll have
like a travel book right and I'll flip
through and try and translate or if I
happen to have a sim in my phone for
that country
bring up you know Google Translate and
I'm trying to enter in the foreign
characters but on glasses you'll see
it's a way cooler experience okay glass
translate this I'm just going to look at
the sign and through glass I'm gonna see
the translation which is pretty cool on
thank you Lisa
and I now know that I'm not gonna jump
off that cliff because I might plummet
to my death that would be bad so these
demos I'm gonna show you quite a few
more of them remember it's a cooler
experience on glass when you actually
try it on glass and everybody in this
room will have a chance to try all of
these demos a little bit later but I
want to sort of show it show them to you
in the context of explaining the GDK so
please you know bear with me even though
it's a little bit more choppy and rezzed
up on the screen now word lens does each
of those three things that you can now
do with the GDK it does offline
processing all that translation is
happening directly on glass without any
internet communication you can switch
languages right I could I could
translate from Spanish to English
English to Portuguese quite a few
languages on word lens and I can do all
of that and switch all of those
languages immediately on glass and then
last but not least is this accessing the
camera and doing that overlay and
translation directly on glass X in that
hardware directly
pretty cool huh okay so let's talk about
the building blocks of what makes
glassware and these are our glassware
components and there's sort of three
areas that I'd like to talk about first
are types
what kind of glassware that you might
want to build in vacation and this is
how you start the glassware
and elements sort of the primary UI
components that are presented to the
user so with types and you'll see all
these lists there they're very simple
and straightforward like development on
glass and there's the GDK which we're
introducing today
all about in the next however long this
takes and the mirror API this is what
you've already been doing with the
cloud-based API and a gtk+ mirror you
can in fact use both of these in a dance
together for a single user experience
now for invocation typically users are
gonna start glassware via the ok glass
menu this is a top-level voice menu that
can trigger your glassware either via
the mirror API or the GDK menu item on a
timeline card so you can interact with a
glassware and even start up a GDK
glassware from the menu item on a
timeline card and timeline cards
themselves which are inserted from the
mirror API and then there's these
elements and let's actually dive deeper
into these elements this is kind of what
they look like the first one live card
so something that you couldn't do on
glass with a mirror API but you can now
do with the GDK now this is something
that gives developers the ability to
draw directly into the glass timeline in
real time and the reason I chose that
particular example is that this is a
stopwatch running on glass with
millisecond updates on glass so you can
actually see that stopwatch count up and
you can scroll through glass to other
parts your timelines scroll back and
that card is still updating static cards
which you already know from the mirror
API this is a moment in time that you
inserts in the users lost timeline as a
timestamp and they can interact with
that card via the menu items immersions
this is another new thing with the GDK
today this is a focused user experience
where the rest of the the glassy works
kind of fades away and they're focused
on just doing that task you saw that
with Word Lens a moment ago and I'll
give you more examples and then
background services now background
services are web services or GDK
services that everyone's will show up
with timeline cards or live cards or
immersions now let's look at an actual
flow here this is a live card flow which
you would typically start with an ok
glass voice command it'll start up a
glassware service now this is an Android
service that creates the live card and
inserts it into the glass timeline now
live cards appear to the left of home
right right your home is your clock and
to the right is everything that's sort
of fade him into the past on your
timeline your history if you will and to
the left is everything that's happening
right now or is about to happen that
includes live cards static cards are
inserted into the glass timeline and
they appear to the right of home as
you'd expect and as you already know
from using the mirror API now immersions
you start with a voice command and they
take over the glass user experience
unlike live cards where if you swipe
forward you go to the next card in the
timeline immersions if you swipe forward
that's captured by that experience and
may be used by that glassware so those
gestures can be used as part of the user
experience
and then finally services and again
these are background services most
mirror API glassware are services it's
something that's running on the cloud
constantly and every once a while throws
the timeline cards your way you can also
run GDK glassware as a service and it
will show up maybe with a live card or
perhaps an immersion when it's important
to the user for it to do so okay so
those are our building blocks and I'm
going to describe each of these a little
bit more later when we get into the
demos more demos but first let's take a
step back and say well what is this GDK
thing the GDK is super straightforward
and simple we worked really hard to make
sure that if you're an Android developer
developing for glass would feel natural
it uses the same paradigms that you're
already used to so we built the GDK with
standard Android ap is compiled for
glass so that when you use those Android
ap eyes on glass it gives you the
experience that it should on glass and
I'll describe some of those in detail in
a moment
for features specific to glass we have a
simple add-on that you add into your
already standard Android development
environment
gives you access to those specific
features things like the live card or
the voice invocation commands all right
so let's look at both those less in a
bit more detail the platform features
are things like the location provider
now those of you that have experienced
directions on glass you know that you
need glass tethered with your Android
phone because glass uses the GPS from
the phone now this complexity is
completely abstracted away when you're
building with the GDK you use the normal
location provider like you would on any
other Android device and the location
will just work when the user has that
Android phone tethered the camera a tent
also works like it should on an Android
device but it'll use the glass camera
the recognizer intent will start up the
glass specific speech-to-text UX and
then the options menu is just an option
options menu like you would have on
Android only on glass it will render a
glass specific menu now the add-on
features these are new things right and
you use the add-on to get these it's a
voice trigger which allows you to insert
commands into the ok glass menu
gesturedetector so as you're moving
around on the touchpad you can capture
those gestures cards and card scroller
which will allow you to build timeline
cards and arrange them on a mini
timeline in your glassware
so the users can scroll through them
like a glass timeline and then live
cards live cards are the that way that
you can draw directly into the glass
timeline and with all these features you
can build the same level of glassware
that's already built into some of the
system glassware such as directions but
we also think that you're going to build
a lot of new and interesting stuff now
when users install these glassware they
go to my glass like normal and they hit
that on button and an apk is downloaded
to their glass device and it'll look
like this to the user they'll see that
card they hit that on switch and then on
glass they see a live card to the left
of home saying
activating this glassware in this case
the example is Word Lens and as soon as
the entire apk is downloaded that card
moves into the timeline and it says
activated really simple flow for users
for glassware that needs authentication
and account and this will be released
soon we're still hammering out a few
details but I'll come out when there's
the full Developer Preview the user goes
through the normal install flow but
they're also given a pop-up window to
your web page where they sign in and
then you Jason encode and Android
Account Manager account send that to a
Google API and then Google will send
that to the users glass so when they run
the glassware on glass the Account
Manager is already populated with that
account now the GDK has all these
features and we're adding more all the
time what's going to be released is a
sneak peek next up is the developer
preview where we'll get things like off
and even more features hopefully based
on a lot of your feedback okay now I
want to give you some really solid use
cases and examples of great glassware
and I'd like to do so sort of in the
perspective of these development
patterns there's about four that we see
developers using to build glassware and
the first two you're already doing with
the mirror API one of these is periodic
notifications you have a service in the
cloud and every one so all you want to
tell to use or something so you send
them a timeline card another one is
sharing the user has an image on glass
and they want to share it out to a
Google+ circle and they just share that
again with a mirror API glassware the
ones that I'm going to dive deeper into
are the GDK patterns that you can do now
but you couldn't do with glass before
the GDK was available one of those is
ongoing tasks the user is doing
something they they want to frequently
look back at that ongoing task a
different information or interact and
the other one is immersion you know
immersion is when the user has a focused
task they want to sort of stop what
they're doing focus on this task for a
little while and then when they exit
back they're back at their normal glass
experience
for ongoing tasks what I'd like to show
you and for all these partners they've
done an incredible job of testing this
API and finding our bugs and really
getting it ready for you to play with
but they also have really cool glassware
glassware that I've enjoyed using
everyday and we think you're gonna love
to one of those is Strava now Strava is
a great service built for athletes that
helps you track your runs and your rides
and about you but I use Strava every
time I'm on my bike but I do find it
kind of annoying and difficult to get my
phone out of whatever pocket I've
decided to stash it in and when I'm
writing I still want the benefits of
Strava and I want to get that coaching
and I want to see that data but I want
to keep my hands on the handlebars and
keep focused on my path and you know the
experience of riding my bike that's why
I'm out there with Strava and glass
you just speak to start tracking you
just look up to see the information that
matters to you and you can see your
personal records relative to your best
times all by just looking up shall we
take a look at this okay so I'm spoofing
location on a tablet here so that it
thinks that I'm out there riding my bike
it works pretty well we'll see how it
looks ok glass start a bike ride and
there I am oh I'm going fast that's
great I don't usually go around the wind
must be at my back and so the great
thing about this is a couple things it's
like all I did would say ok last start a
bike ride and it started there were no
settings there were no things to
navigate I wasn't looking for the app on
my you know it just it happened for me
and that's the glass experience also the
last one to stand by but if I want I
just look up and there's all my straw of
information it's pretty cool right um
and if I let's say if I tap you can see
that I can go through my segment history
those of you who use straw every day you
know they have these cool segments and
one of the things that I like to do is
if I know where the segment is I ride
faster because that's the thing this
gets recorded
I can share with my friends and
typically I just sort of like have to
know where that segment is well it was
travel on glass it tells me as I just
start the segment about halfway through
and near the end as well so that I'm
really charging as fast as I can so I
can get that good time and then as I
passed through the segments it will load
up the segment history with what I've
passed and as a segment ongoing it'll
create an additional life card like this
one right here that was good timing so
this is Hawk Hill which is a great climb
in San Francisco I have not done it in
six minutes but it may be today I will
when I have pretend GPS now I can look
at this and it's giving me my my
progress on this segment anyway I'm
gonna go back to the straw of experience
here I'm gonna tap and hit finish and it
saved the ride and it's uploaded to
Strava and I can share it with my
friends later
pretty cool huh all right so I just show
you the demo I want to now look at the
flow just on a static page here and
describe some of the platform features
that Strava is using to make this happen
so the voice command is invoked by the
user and then this live card is created
now you'll notice that Strava
looks like a glass where it looks like
the rest of the glass experience is
consistent and it's familiar to the user
and that's because theming is built into
the SDK so all of those sort of like
minor implementation details or on
colors and fonts you just get that free
with the GDK also they're using live
cards to draw directly into the timeline
which means that time is ticking as you
would expect I can zoom around that
timeline I can zoom out and at that live
card is still going it's directly
rendering into my timeline and then
Strava is also using authentication to
start this up I use the flow that I
mentioned before where I clicked on I
signed into my Strava account that
account got sent down to glass and then
Strava just used it using the normal
an Android Account Manager alright let
me show you another one and this is I'm
gonna need some more GPS spoofing for
this this is golf site by sky droid golf
is another one of those things that I
like to do or I do not want technology
in the way but I still want the benefits
of it for example when I'm choosing my
club I want to know kind of how far I am
to the green and that changes as you
know because you hit and then you're in
the fairway or in my case you're usually
off to the right and I'm not sure how
far I am to the green but with golf
sight I'll always know how far I am both
to the front middle and the back of the
green the hazards that are on the course
and all of that just by looking up you
want to see it okay
let me just go ahead and say ok glass
start it around golf so it's gonna find
nearby golf courses and sky droid is so
great even though it's through from my
GPS and it's not working well I can just
select the park that I want which is
Golden Gate Park Golf Course hey that's
gonna load it up and there I am huh
there we are 149 yards to the hole and
you'll notice this hole is a par 3 which
is my skill level and probably still had
5 and if I want I can just tap on this
card and maybe swipe over to the hazards
and targets I know there's a bunker just
to the right of the green and all this
information I get while I'm on the
course without breaking my stride and
it's never in the way when I don't want
it to be once I get to that green and
with a little bit of wishful thinking
let's say birdie shall we let's pretend
it can be whatever I want and now I'm on
to the second Hall super simple but
everything that I otherwise would have
been like ruffling in my bag or like
maybe in the middle of the fairway it
knows because it has access to my
location and it's giving me that
information exactly what I need it let's
go ahead and end this round and we're
done
okay so that's golf site um
again let me take a moment to talk about
the GDK features that a golf site by sky
droid is using and there's voice
invocation and then I select the course
and it lands on this page where I've got
an options menu now this options menu is
your Android options menu but when it's
rendered on glass it's a glass menu and
that's that second row there also um
they are using the live card like Strava
and the location provider so they're
accessing GPS all throughout my game to
know exactly where I am and they're
doing this like normal on Android with
the location provider okay so let's talk
about this next pattern which is
immersion alright and this is this is
really new for glass it's when the user
wants to have a focused task in front of
them where the rest of the UI kind of
fades away and a great example of this
is game play now new form factors always
open up incredible possibilities for
game play and our friends at Glu built
this really cool games balista and one
of my favorite things about this is the
natural interface it allows me to play
this game completely hands-free should
we take a look okay okay glass play a
game and here we aren't police it's a
word jumble game and I'm playing the
level under the sea and I'm terrible at
it but Jeff in the front row is really
good what is this Turtles is it le or al
sub turtles crabs okay you guys don't
mind if I just play this for a little
while do you
it's fun so super simple and easy and I
love playing this I just about any time
during my day because it's always right
there whenever I want it now another
cool thing about this game is they built
this really cool that was dolphins I
know they built his really cool feature
that lets me build my own levels and I
can share them with my friends and Leon
built this Red Sox Nation go figure
level that I can play and she actually
took a picture on glass and then spoke
some words aloud and that just created
the level and she could send it to me
again from glass which is a really cool
way to stay in touch with your friends
and family when you're far away this is
somebody said New York and so again very
simple and intuitive and the the
interface is just delightful the way the
scene moves around as I look around and
it's really glanceable and still feels
very glass like alright so let's look at
some of the tools from the GDK that who
used to builds police stuff so it's the
voice invocation like before only this
voice invocation then creates an Android
activity that Android activity is the
immersion it's just your normal Android
activity but on glass it creates that
immersion and then balista is using a
couple really cool things here you
notice that first row these are sort of
rich imagery that represents the levels
they're using the cards class to build
those cards and they're using the card
scroller class to make this feel like a
natural glass timeline they're also
using the gyroscope and they're using
the gyroscope like normal like you would
on anything any other Android device
except now it's me moving my head in
this natural way okay another immersion
example is Word Lens now I've already
showed you the demo so let me just give
you the details Word Lens as this really
cool real-time translation overlay
right but on glass I think you saw it's
really what makes it come alive all I
need to do is look at the text I want
translated and through glass I see it
translated into my natural language and
I think the cool thing that I want to
mention about word lens is once I invoke
it it immediately uses the camera and
accesses that camera feed directly does
some optical character recognition using
the NDK on glass like you would on any
other Android device computes the
translation and overlays that on the
video and shows that back to me they're
also using the gyroscope so that
whenever it knows I'm looking at
something that's when it starts
translating that so again it uses these
these features of the GDK they're really
straightforward Android paradigms but
now makes it a glass specific natural
experience all right one more demo one
more demo all the cooks now all the
cooks is a social cooking app for
Android and iPhone and it is really cool
and I found with using Auto cooks I'm
cooking more because recipes are there
but also I'm doing something that I
never did before because of all the
cooks on glass I'm actually taking
pictures and recording notes on my
recipes and sending them to my friends
and I remember did this before because
it was always kind of in the way you
know I just kind of get the camera and
they're like the notepad I'm like I need
a better shot and then it's burnt
alright it's just sort of like an
awkward experience but cooking you
really need your hands and that's where
a glass really shines in this case okay
glass find a recipe oops okay glass find
a recipe on the PATA edited the old
cover the microphone trick for there we
are
for the live demo that works great the
first time so um all the cooks is now
searching for avocado recipes on the
internet and I get some really cool
pictures here I'm gonna scroll over back
and choose avocado relish
and here's my recipe I can swipe forward
and back through like these recipes
steps and again I can follow this step
hands-free and if ever like I forget how
many avocados or onions I just look up
and there's my ingredients list it's
really nice it's simple it's intuitive
it's that natural user interface you'd
expect on glass and I don't know about
you but usually when I'm cooking it
takes a long time because I've got to
try things two or three times before I
get it right and with all the cooks on
glass they also insert a live card so I
can get back to that experience easily
on my glass timeline whenever I want
okay so let's take a look at this again
and the GDK implementation details they
use to make this experience happen so
all the cooks is using cards and card
scroller when it created those recipes
and they were bundles and it tapped into
them and you were able to drill down all
that is building with the cards class
and using the card scroller to keep that
natural timeline interface that you
expect on glass they're also using the
recognizer intent now this again is the
recognizer intent from Android but on
glass when you run it gives you the
glass specific speech-to-text interface
okay so those patterns were periodic
notifications and sharing which you
already do on the mirror API and the new
ones that are possible today with the
GDK are ongoing tasks and immersion now
all these partners that we've been
working with again they've done a great
job of helping us test the platform but
also I've really loved using these
glassware on glass day in and day out
and we think that you will - all of
these will be available on my glass
later today and we have a couple more
simple blasts where that we're throwing
on there um the compass and the
stopwatch both GDK glassware that we
built and open source and they're going
to be available on the documentation if
you to learn how to use the GDK even
quicker and the mirror API has been
going strong and more people have been
submitting their glassware for review
and three more just got available and
we're gonna be launching today as well
amano which allows you to get trending
news articles on glass read to you by
professional voice actors so you can get
your news while still on the go I'm
Jewish guide for glass let's say you're
traveling in a local place and you need
some kosher food you can set a reminder
on Jewish guide and it will come up at
lunchtime with all the kosher
restaurants nearby and if this than that
if this then that has a ton of cool
recipes that you can use now with glass
say for example you're looking for an
apartment in San Francisco you can use
if this than that to get notified as
soon as a news new listing is posted on
Craigslist so all this stuff is going to
be available later today on my glass and
it joins a lot of the glassware that's
already up there it's just a handful of
glassware that we have on my glass
because we're just getting started and
even even so we've been delighted and
surprised by the cool new things that
people want to do with glass but today
now that the GDK is available more than
ever we're excited to see
you will do next both of things that we
know you're gonna do with this that are
great use cases on glass and the things
that we haven't even thought of yet
because one thing we know about our
Explorer community is you guys dream
really big and we can't wait to see how
you make those dreams tangible with the
glass development kit
let's take a look wick look at the walk
through just so you know how easy it is
to get started with the glass
development kit so again I keep saying
this is Android development that you're
used to let's go ahead and load up
Eclipse with ADT now this is pretty much
fresh install on my computer here and
remember there was a the part of the GDK
that's built into the platform on glass
using normal Android platform api's but
they'll just work on glass the way they
should and then there's the add-on
library that gives you deeper access to
the glass specific features well you
need to get that add-on library before
you start building on the GDK and it's
available through the SDK manager now
I've already gone ahead and installed it
it's this item right here you look under
API level 15 and you'll see glass
development kit sneak peek you click on
that install the package read the
license and accept the Terms and then
come back to your Eclipse interface now
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to create
a new sample project from the add-on so
I'm just going to go to file new other
and I'm gonna choose Android sample
project and select the glass development
kit let's try the stopwatch
okay so I've got the stopwatch here and
I'm gonna choose a let's just run it see
what happens then choose my glass device
click OK now I might have another
stopwatch at a PK here but it just
compiled it and now it's installing it
and done cool so let's take a look at my
glass device
ok glass start a stopwatch and there it
is from installing Eclipse 2 on glass in
what was that a minute 2 minutes
that's the GDK
okay so the GDK and the documentation
are right now a sneak peek that means
the full Developer Preview is coming
later but we still wanted to give it to
you guys to get your hands on it so you
could test it find some bugs and also
find the stuff that's missing that you
really want to really be able to make
great glassware so we're making it
available as the sneak peek later today
and you'll find the instructions for
getting the add-on and all the
documentation at
developers.google.com/plus now we are
just getting started and we do want that
feedback we want to build this platform
with you so please just add a slash
community on the end of that URL and
you'll come to links for our Stack
Overflow tag so our issue tracker we
really want to hear from you about how
we can make this platform great
and then finally Android development
this is all the GDK is built on the
Android platform so you also want to
take a look at that documentation to get
started and again what's really gonna
happen next is you get to build
glassware using the mirror API and now
with all these new features that are
available to you through the the GDK
that really open up these magical
experiences that let you build glassware
that fit into people's lives in a
natural way a lot of the stuff that you
saw today wasn't available on glass
before the GDK and then you just
couldn't do that kind of user experience
but a lot of those demos also you may
have noticed weren't possible before
glass there's something about this form
factor that really opens up a new realm
of possibilities for building great user
experiences and solving real user
problems and we can't wait to see you do
just that with the GDK thank you so much